Jean-Jacques Rousseau's philosophy of
education is based on the idea that
children should develop a strong
virtuous character the ability to reason
and a refined sense of sentiment this is
so that as adults they are able to
resist Temptations think for themselves
and learn to appreciate the Finer Things
in life
[Music]
to explain his ideas Rousseau wrote Emil
or on education the book tells the story
of a boy who goes through childhood
Boyhood pre-adolescence adolescence and
adulthood all five stages happen under
the guardianship of his parents and a
tutor
stage one Early Childhood begins with
Emil's birth during the stage it is
essential for his parents to ensure that
Emile develops physically only the
mother should feed the boy because she
naturally loves him more than anyone
else to allow the boy to make
experiences with all his senses he wears
loose clothing and is placed in a large
cradle where he can move freely Rousseau
who was influenced by John Locke
believed that dressing children too
warmly makes them weak
if a meal doesn't want to eat he's
supported if he wants to use his left
hand he can beating or shouting at the
boy should be avoided when Emil cries
which Rousseau called our first language
his mother should try to understand him
and find the underlying cause since
children are born essentially good it is
the responsibility of the parents to
Shield them from those who could
influence their innocent Minds
during stage 2 Boyhood Emil is educated
to perfect his senses this is important
because the mind needs a wide range of
trained senses to perceive information
correctly and develop good judgment
instead of recommending books the tutor
lets Emil play games and conduct natural
experiments outside the city or a school
are not the right places for a child at
this age
Emil learns to tell right from wrong by
experiencing the consequences of his
actions instead of actively teaching the
tutor is merely a bystander who is there
to protect the boy from those who want
to influence his thinking or teach him
bad habits over time Emil learns
morality and virtue naturally
in stage 3 pre-adolescence Emil is ready
to learn how to reason Russo thought
that only self-directed learning led to
the discipline necessary to acquire real
knowledge the tutor therefore trusts
Emil's interests and if the boy wants to
learn history history he learns
languages are acquired naturally through
conversations
Emil is also taught carpentry a manual
labor that requires creativity and
intellect which helps him to become a
virtuous adult who knows the value of
hard work doing such work also keeps a
meal out of trouble and allows him to
make a living in the event of a change
in fortune
in stage 4 adolescence Emil is ready for
the last part of his education sentiment
only now is he capable of understanding
complex emotions such as true compassion
Emile now becomes a loving person who
learns to live with and for others or as
Russo wrote we have made an active and
thinking being it remains for us in
order to complete the man only to make a
loving and feeling being that is to say
to perfect Reason by sentiment
the tutor now begins formal education
and introduces the passionate boy to
Concepts such as religion children who
learn such complex ideas earlier are
unable to think about them freely and
hence just recite what they have been
told Emil whose character has grown
strong enough to reason is now permitted
to mingle with people in society
in Stage 5 adulthood Emil becomes a
virtuous man who can make up his own
mind he visits the city and develops a
sense for the Finer Things in life
thanks to his strong character the
pursuit of wealth or other Temptations
are none of his interests the young man
is now ready to meet Sophie the perfect
woman his wife to be
Sophie a representative of the ideal
woman is educated to be governed by her
husband while Emil a representative of
the ideal man is educated to be
self-governing the man should be strong
and active the woman should be weak and
passive Rousseau wrote Sophie's purpose
is to please advise and console her
husband
once published Rousseau's books were
widely criticized burned and banned the
church and state issued a warrant for
Rousseau's arrest in addition modern
women disagreed with his ideas or saw
him a hypocrite Rousseau himself sent
away all five of his children to
orphanages nevertheless Emil became
Rousseau's most important work and a
pillar of modern education
but what are your thoughts do you think
Emil receives the ideal education to
become a truly free-thinking mind is it
right to try to protect children from
society's influence or was Russo wrong
about education tell us what you think
in the comments below
thank you
[Music]
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com